We're going to talk about the war
today. Let's do it. Let's do that. Now.
I assume that you guys all saw,
uh, um, uh, paths of glory.
And so I'm going to talk about
the mutinies and in awhile. Um,
and then Jay winter is
going to talk about, uh,
essentially the great war and modern
memory. Uh, and I'm going to end,
so make a nice transition to his lecture.
I'm going to end with something
that he wrote about how reality and,
and art came together in
a terrifying way in 1918.
Okay. Now I'm almost feel
sauce, just going to say.
Okay. Um, so just a few
things. Uh, you know,
at the beginning of their
obvious through in the book. Um,
but it didn't work out the way
Falcon Heine wanted it to. Uh,
and of course the point, I mean,
this leaf and wanted it to a, and a,
the point about the Belgium, uh,
it'd be invasion of Belgium, uh,
was of course that it brought a
Britain of the war. And, uh, the, the,
the Germans were counting on the fact
that it would take Britain a very,
very long time to raise,
uh, an army, not a navy,
been an army of any size and what they
call the British expeditionary force does
arrive and takes his place
and next to the French,
but it's very small and they
don't have conscription until, uh,
late in the war because they,
unlike the French,
I did not have military conscription.
But basically to make a
long story short, um, I,
is that the, in part because, uh,
Germany as France, as everybody was
worried about the home front, uh,
basically what happens is,
is they,
they hurt their chances of pulling this
off by moving some divisions to Alsace,
uh, to try to blunt the, the, the
force there. And also some more, uh,
are headed off to the eastern front
because they start to realize that the
Russians are mobilizing more rapidly
than they thought they could. Um,
and so basically, um, it's possible
to argue that the battle of the Marne,
uh, saves a, saves Paris, um, and,
and saves France, uh, because, um,
and sleeping would've gone
crazy about this. Remember,
he's the last thing he said
that supposedly in his life
was let the last soldier
touching was channel and then
come down and hit. I hit Paris.
But they turned down before that.
Um,
and the first airplanes that are used as
reconnaissance planes, they, you know,
the, the pilot's literally, you know,
had to have carried pistols
with them at the very beginning,
and they had not figured out a way to
put machine guns on that, that wouldn't,
the bullets wouldn't hit the propeller
and then come back and kill the pilot.
So all this took a,
uh,
took some doing with the first planes
where we're kind of sauce planes. And, uh,
at one point in, in, uh, this, this huge
engagement, futuring, just enormous,
enormous armies, uh, in the German
case supplied by trains going, uh, uh,
many every hour across the Rhine.
Uh, the, the, the French, um,
uh, a plane, see that there's
a big, uh, uh, a gap in, in,
in the German lines.
And so they counter attack.
And the famous story everybody knows, uh,
and again, what do I want to insist on?
It is, I mean, look at where it
says the battle of the Marne.
There's a town called [inaudible].
They're at now is practically a
suburb of Paris lag. And why? Uh,
and you could hear, I mean, you
could hear, uh, the battle in Paris.
You could hear the, the, uh, you know,
the, the roll of thunder of the guns.
And one thing that has to, when you
ask how the, the French Home Front, uh,
holds together so long, he said, the
Germans are so close. And in 1918,
there'll be close again. In 1918,
they're firing this huge gun,
which the British soldiers called Big
Bertha. And it's lobbying from way,
way the hell up in the north.
In the north is lobbying shells from
the German lines behind the German lines
all the way to Paris on Easter Sunday,
1918 hitting apartment house on,
uh, the Church of Santa Fe and
apartment house on the boulevard.
A run on the [inaudible], not too
far from, uh, uh, from our place.
And so there, there's the Germans are
so close, but in 1914, what happens is,
is that, I mean, literally the,
the commander of Paris who's that name is
Galliani and as has attack, he has, uh,
he has a metro stop named after him.
It's a lot of these guys do a,
he commandeers the Paris taxis and they're
literally carrying a soldiers out to
the front at the battle of the Marne.
And what happens is the battle of the
Marne stops the German advance and then
the race to the seed begins, uh, and they
tried to outflank each other. And again,
to borrow a ridiculous football analogy,
but it's not so ridiculous.
It doesn't matter if you don't
follow football, but you know,
if you're trying to get
around the outside, you know,
you're trying to get around outside before
the outside linebacker can get there,
uh,
and you're trying to turn the corner.
And so basically that's
what they're trying to do.
Both sides are trying to turn the
corner and they end up, you know,
if they end up at the sea. Uh,
and, uh, at that point, uh,
the trenches are dug literally
from the sea all the way to,
uh, to Switzerland. Uh, and so the war,
uh, to repeat what I said the other day,
only a couple people who had seen the, uh,
what was going on in the Russell
Japanese war of 1904, 1905,
I could have imagined that this war in
which the office was supposed to have
the, as an 1870, 71, uh,
was supposed to have every
advantage. Remember, uh,
the French commander said a long
vetol, we need this, the frenetic,
a patriotic energy. That's all we need.
We need to attack and keep on attacking.
It doesn't work out that way.
And the reason that you have all of these
millions of people killed the flower
of British youth, the flower of
every youth in that period, uh,
is because this offensive war becomes
a defensive struggle in which breaking
through is almost literally impossible,
thus backdrop to what you
have seen in, in, uh, in,
in paths of glory. And that the weapons,
the defense, the, the, the, the,
the weapons of the war,
uh,
including really the shelling.
Most people are killed by
shells in World War One,
then dying in any other way. And
they're new and horrible ways of dying.
Flame throwers, for example, poison gas,
which was first used by the Germans that
Hipo one of the many battles of EAP.
There's 12 battles of the same
river, uh, in northern Italy.
Um, and there, there are several
battles of the Somme. I mean,
these battles keep on happening
because large chunks of real estate are
virtually impossible to, uh, to conquer.
And so trenches are defensive weapons.
Uh,
and, and what, what makes that,
one of the reasons that the breakthrough
is impossible is that when you,
you know, you're going to try to
break through these trenches, uh,
what did they have is what they call
creeping barrages and where the, you know,
they start trying to end.
Lots of people died with what the
Americans call friendly fire. Uh,
they try to coordinate
the, the shelling. Uh,
so to go in advance of the people going
over the top and then trying to carry 60
pounds, pick up 60 pounds sometimes.
Where's this stuff on your back?
And to get down into these
horrible creative crater's
full of all sorts of crap
and dead floating rats and dead floating
bodies of human beings and to try to
get to break through. And then you run
into machine guns and machine guns,
which can fire, what is it, 600 something.
I just saw this this morning or
last night, 600 rounds a minute. Uh,
um,
and,
and the Gatling guns had first been used
and I think in the American civil war,
but these are much more
rapid firing and they just,
they aim basically that your knees and
they just sort of go back and forth,
back and forth.
And then Barb wire,
one of the things that soldiers had
to carry with them or wire cutters and
sometimes a wire cutters weren't
equal to the task of cutting the wire.
It's hard to keyer cut wire if you know
people are firing machine guns at you as
well. And so that's why, uh, the trenches,
which you'll see some real
ones in in a minute, uh, are,
you know, fairly elaborate,
elaborate a defensive, uh, uh, uh,
weapons and everybody has seen
the footage of a real battle. Uh,
um, I mean sometimes they've wrecked
it, but the imperial war museum, it,
which used to be much better than it is
now in London is really worth seeing.
And they used to have this amazing small,
a clip of it.
You see these three guys and they're
about ready to go. And the guy,
one guy blows his whistle to follow me
and the first guy goes up and he gets his
head over. Then he's kind of,
he's dead. He falls back in,
the second guy goes up and he gets a
little further than you see his body hit.
And then the third guy, when the film,
the cliff ends is just about to get out.
And you don't know what happens to them,
but it's, chances weren't very good. Um,
so breaking through, I mean it's, it's
their debates on how ridiculous the, uh,
these people like Nevada, we're or
you know, a [inaudible] and the,
and the whole gang, uh, because they keep,
they keep ordering these attacks.
The breakthrough is going to come next.
We really got them.
We're going to break through,
but they don't break through and they
don't break through. And that again,
is battles for, they can't break
through. Uh, and that is is, um,
that is background for,
uh, for the mutinies. Um,
and the first real breakthrough
doesn't come until March 19, 18.
And the Luton Dorf offensive in 1918
and then they run over, run their spa,
their supplies, and it kind of snaps
back like a rubber band and pushes them,
pushes them back.
And if the Germans at that point for
reasons I'll explain in a minute, uh, no,
that they're not going to win the
war. They can't win the war. But what,
what happens,
it's going to happen is that the,
when the war ends and more about
this when we talk about the post war,
is that the war ends with
German troops far inside France.
So how do you explain that back to the
home front and the, and the, and, and, uh,
the, uh, Berlin homefront
has started to collapse a,
there's great a deprivation, great to, uh,
problems getting enough to eat and the,
and that situation. And that will
make it easier later for Hitler.
And many other little would be Hitler's
to argue that the were winning,
but you were stabbing back by the Jews
and the communists and the Socialists and
the peaceniks and all of these people,
uh, from, from their point of view.
And so, uh, when you do these
creeping barrages, you know,
you're indicating where the
attacks going to come and, and,
and the trenches behind the trenches,
the Germans as to the French have
railroad lines that are used to bring in
reinforcements to bring in supplies.
And so we,
what you do is you bring in supplies,
you bring in reinforcements. Um, and so,
uh, if you read a great book
by Paul Fussell, F U S, s,
e l or two L's, F, U, s, s, e, l,
l I think called the great war and
modern memory. It's about the war poets.
It's about Siegfried staff
soon and Wilfred Owen and,
and, and folks like that.
Eisenberg, I, I quote him in the, I
think one of his poems in the book.
And that is an amazing
look at the whole thing.
I mean that's a readymade paper
topic that take a couple of those,
those plums and, and talk about
the talk about the war. Um,
and so I mean breaking through is very,
very difficult.
Uh, it's almost impossible and
that's why you have the carnage.
That's why you have, as I said, the
very first day if you were here, uh,
that there are more bitter soldiers
killed or seriously wounded in the first
three days of the battle of the Somme.
Somn m m e like the river.
Then there were Americans killed
in world war one, Korea in Vietnam
in three days,
the first three days.
So you're talking about horrific losses,
you're talking about an expectation and
we try to put yourself in the same thing.
Uh, I think I have that quote
in there. Somebody said,
you discuss your own death as if
you're discussing a lunch that you were
planning tomorrow.
And someone else said,
I didn't want to die at least until
I'd finished reading the return of the
native.
Uh,
and so that again is
background for the mutinies.
And what is amazing is, is that,
and again, the French situation,
because of the precariousness,
it's difficult to explain how
people could have continued to,
to fight in many ways. And, and again,
looking at the Austrian Hungarian
empire where they had a huge losses, uh,
is that the army's hold together really
until 1917 and even beyond the Austrian
Hungarian empire and the Russian
case to us, our market, well,
the battle of Tannenberg, uh,
it's just, it's just, you know,
an amazing battle in 1914 in the,
and the Russian, uh, you know,
there's so many casualties.
They couldn't even count them.
There's so many people dead and
there never been a war like this.
No one had ever seen, couldn't
have imagined a war like this. Um,
and the proximity also,
I mean the English had the,
had the advantage of having the channel
there, but there, but it's one of these,
if you've been to Victoria station,
I mean it's one of these things they
always say about the war, but it's true,
is that you go to the officer's club and
in Victoria station have a decent lunch,
knocked down a couple of
pints of beer and you,
and you're on the front and the early
evening and can be dead by early evening.
Uh, and it is sad that in Kent we
did these, these, these, uh, minors,
he's Welsh, mine, Welsh minors,
uh, in Belgium. They crawl,
they tunneled under this,
the sort of promitory that sticking up a,
that's a defensive position for
the, uh, for the Germans. And they,
they bring in all these, these, uh,
munitions and they blow the thing up.
They blow this huge thing
up and, and, and can't,
supposedly it is sad that people
in Kent, you know, I, I, uh, uh,
on and near the coast of the English
Channel could actually hear the explosion.
So the war is, the war is that close?
And of course it's close in other ways.
Is that the, that every imagine
that you lived in, you know,
living in a village and the in France
or anywhere and the fact to the,
in our case, the fuck the, uh, the, um,
the mail carrier comes and what you don't
want to see is you don't want the mail
carrier to come to your house.
You don't want mail because he,
uh, I would be carrying a
telegram saying, be proud of x,
who has just died for you feel
in the country. Turkey, Bulgaria,
Romania, France, Germany,
Russia, Britain, anywhere.
Um, so it became a war,
like, like no other war. And,
and, uh, with the only possible exception
that's the Spanish civil war has given,
has given birth to really the greatest
writing about, but arguably any,
a,
any war,
certainly in history and arguably any
events outside of maybe the rise of Hitler
and national socialism in
Germany because it was, uh, uh,
it was like that. And it really
couldn't have been a, uh,
it couldn't have been any, uh, any other
way. And they're still trying to, uh, uh,
they're still arguing over these
battles, that passion. Dale,
we once drove up posh and Dale was one
of these places that they first used
poison gas and, and, uh, uh, you know,
now there's a lot of low t small,
a lot of 'em in Belgium will,
a lot of housing developments and I just
wanted to go and see their, and you,
you can't even see there where the
hell that was. Passion Dale, uh,
was actually there. Um, if you're
going to go see these battlefields,
so the one to go to his Israel in which
were done, which I'll talk about in, in,
uh, in a minute because I had had it
there. You can go through these forts. Do,
I'm all and Volvo I n n you
can imagine when it's like,
and you can see some places
where they've left. Uh,
they've in the winds and the myths and
the terrible weather of that part of
France and the one road going
from Barla Duke supplying, uh, uh,
the on the sacrum is sacred roads
applying, very done that they've eye.
You still see a, there's one place
where they've left the, you know,
the guns with their bayonets. And there
was a lot of hand to hand fighting there.
And, and that's the place
where Falcon Heights said,
we can afford to lose more children,
a more young people, more young men.
We will simply out bleed them.
And he hurdles one attack after another,
over most of 1916 against fair done.
And that's where so many,
uh, so many people a die.
And of course that is that as
the background also, uh, for,
uh, uh, for these, uh, for these,
these mutinies ousel. Okay. Um,
oh yeah,
we used to do that.
Okay. Here, here we've got,
uh, you know, here's the,
the western front in 19 six, 1915, 1917.
And you could see that it really doesn't,
you know, it doesn't move at all.
But again, I mean, look, there is Paris
and there was fighting. And by the way,
these places like Raf Raf, so
rei, m s, the beautiful cathedral,
which was rebuilt thanks to
the Americans after the war,
the Carnegie family gave a lot of
money and ordinary people rebuilt.
The cathedral is one of the great
cathedrals anywhere in Europe or house was
right on the line. And of
course, ranch just got pounded.
The whole place was just
totally devastated. Ah, Aha.
So the uh, there's another,
uh, example, uh, uh, up there,
um, right, right on the line. And I
can't remember on the first day or not,
if I didn't relate a story of, of
people that we knew, uh, five, uh, no,
about now,
about eight years ago who were actually
killed because of world war one a,
they were killed as a family. We
knew in, in who are cousins from, uh,
of really good friends of ours and would
come, they would come down there and,
and there was a boy I the
age of my daughter then and
there, I guess he was 12.
Then. Uh, and, uh, we met
them and we, you know, simple.
We hadn't had a good time talking to them.
And then I asked what,
how they weren't Thanksgiving
when I went over to thanksgiving.
Not that in France we don't celebrate
thanksgiving, but I hadn't 10 days,
so why not? Um, and there were dad,
I'm not the father, but the, the,
the son and the mother had been killed
by World War One because they live,
their house was right up in our Haas
and in the basement they had a fire.
This was just a few, you know, you
were 10 years old when this happened.
This was world war one.
Still, I'm still killing.
And they were killed because there
was a fire in their basement.
They didn't know that
another side of the wall, uh,
we're all these munitions stocked
right near the Front World War One.
And the fire caught and it blew up
the house and the father wasn't there.
And this, this guy, this little guy
and his, his mother were killed,
were blown up,
killed by world war one in 1920s
there were people killed all the time.
You just still,
for every couple a weeks,
you still see in the paper
now that they found, you know,
bomb and Berlin from World War Two,
from all the bombing or,
or in dressed in and all these other
places in war one there. We're constantly,
you know,
farmers were blown up as they were
plowing constantly as they were plowing on
the, on these battlefields around
the Shema. They, dom for example,
which is up near a while,
you can see the psalm there,
that's a good one to have a there, but
this Chavela they, dom is up near there.
It's north of, of swift song. Uh,
anyway, and if you go to any of those,
they pop them all. If you go up,
uh, say, uh, uh, well, any of them,
if you go to the Martin,
which is where the song basically was
a or into the product, Calais, uh,
which is Pickety there, uh, you can
see they're just fields and fields,
these cemeteries, uh, with, uh,
uh, hundreds of thousands of,
of, uh, of crosses and when one
can go on and on about this,
but there'd never been anything like it.
And it's a war became the
dominant experience, uh,
in the lives of Europeans,
period.
No matter how old you were because
you knew somebody who died,
you had a relative who died period.
There are in France where
much of the fighting was,
the western front fighting was there and
in Belgium there are 36,000 communes,
which is an administrative unit.
36,012 out of 36,000 had
nobody killed in war one.
And there are places you can go,
particularly if you're in the
south of France where you can go.
Where they did didn't, they didn't have
any reason they were all taken. You know,
if people were skilled workers who could
work in munitions factories, you know,
could get out.
And there are a lot of tensions between
rural and urban people because there was
an urban people who had
rationing problems, had
owed, you know, it's a rural,
people are, are hoarding their, their
pro pro products and stuff like that.
But there are places you can go where
you see these and I count, I'm a counter,
I count things all the time. It's
maddening. You'll find there's one town,
there is 74 people died.
Very small town in south of France
in a place called to having at home.
And you know, there's hardly 74
houses and there's a village.
It's quite beautiful as
a 12th century church,
way up in the seven mountains about
where we take tourists, you know, uh,
and there's a, when you
walk there, uh, the,
the monument to the dad
is inside the church.
And when you show people this
beautiful a renaissance, uh, entryway,
and there's 12 people killed in
the war and that you cannot count,
two aren't 12 houses. You can't count 12
houses. People don't live there anymore.
Hardly anyone's there. So the, I mean,
we know more about the western front and
now there's some good books appearing
on the eastern front,
but it's the same thing in every country
that you're talking about. But as the,
the,
the list of people,
percentages or the numbers of people
killed around will make clear what the
country is, where that really suffered
the most. And, and they were, uh,
whether they were Germany and France,
and then they followed by, uh, by Russia,
but also Britain. And don't forget
in Britain. And remember I said that,
that the four empires disappear.
Well,
the fifth empire arguably disappears
in the end because of, of,
of dynamics caused by the war.
Because after people,
people in the so called colonies,
the fighting for the British empire,
they began to think, well, why
shouldn't we have independence?
Why shouldn't we have freedom to, and
of course, at the battle of globally,
which is one of the great
tragedies of the war,
when Churchill who had 10 ideas
a day and nine of them were bad,
it's one of his critics said, uh, you
know, Churchill said, well, why don't we,
you know, we'll take the
pressure off by, we'll, uh,
we'll have to knock the
Turks out of the war.
And so they're going to have this
impossible assault on Turkish fortified
positions. And so they said, well,
we'll knock them out of the war with
the Australians and the Indians and the,
and the New Zealanders and, uh, you know,
we can afford to lose them more easily.
You know, they're not really ours. Uh,
and of course that still resonates in
places like New Zealand and Australia and
in India as well. It should. But anyway,
that's another complicated story and we
have, we have other stuff to do. So, um,
you know, read things on this. It is,
it is, uh, you know, it is a phenomenal,
a phenomenal thing.
The mutinies just a little
bit to the mutinies to Psalm.
You can read about him and all of that.
When I used to work at the vast
sand in the military archives there,
cause I was writing about 1830 and 18,
48 and all that stuff,
I was reading day by day,
you know,
the correspondence from various regions
in France. And, and I was trying to find,
um, I was fine to find these documents
that I knew that I knew were there.
This was when I was just starting out. I
wasn't much older than you guys. And, um,
I'd like to think that. And, um, uh,
you know, younger than I once was,
but you know, anyway, here,
whatever the song is, um,
and I knew this stuff was there
and the person that ran it was the,
was out having a sort of a torrid
affair with this guy all the time.
And so she was never there at lunch
and she didn't know what she was doing
anyway. And so I bribed one of the, the,
the guards to let me back in the,
in the,
in the stacks where you're not
supposed to go and French archives,
but the guy was a stamp collector.
So I kept leaving all these jazzy and
I knew that I left all these jazz,
he stamps on the, on my table and finally
said, oh, those are beautiful stamps.
What would you like them? And the
next thing I knew, I'm in the,
I mean in the back,
but I remember what I saw was this
huge number of thing of boxes.
This is in the mid seventies is huge
number of boxes that were chained up.
Literally.
They were in this cage and they were
chained up and I mean really chained up,
you know, with big locks and all that
stuff, big security. And I said, well,
we know what's all that. And he said,
well, those are the mutiny documents.
Those are the documents from the
mutinies in 1917 and now finally,
a guy was able to get in,
because in France there's a 50 year rule
and he should have been able 50 years
after the fact,
you should be able to consult documents.
And this guy was finally able to get, uh,
uh, they were, as they call it, to it,
to get, you know, an exception
to go work on these documents.
And so the thesis that was published is
very good by a guy called g Pedrol Sini
who am, I don't know. And it's on the
mutiny. So now we know about the mutinies.
So how,
you know,
what do we know about the mutinies that
that confirms what you saw, uh, in, uh,
in the film, um, that, uh,
several things is that the
Munis were spread rapidly.
They did indeed begin with,
with uh,
soldiers who were being sent to the front,
buying like sheep as if they were
being sent to a slaughter house.
Cause that's where they're being sent to.
What's the difference between a soldier
carrying 60 pounds of equipment going to
some attack that's going to go nowhere,
whereas chances of being killed or
enormous and sheep being led to a
slaughterhouse, what is the
difference? Really, not much,
except you're dealing with a human
being and not and, and not a sheep. Um,
and so that was a bad sign
for these officers. And um,
when the mutiny started, there were
only really for reliable divisions.
They figured at one point between
Paris and the German lines,
the incredible thing was it's because
soldiers never talk about the battle when
they went go back.
They don't talk about the battle.
Okay.
It was impossible to
communicate what was going on.
And the mutinies were one of the
well kept secrets. Nobody knew.
The Germans didn't know at the time.
Hardly anybody knew.
Nobody is probably too
strong. Um, but the,
the mutinies involved thousands and
thousands and thousands of soldiers.
And some cases they elected people to
represent them in a few cases where the
officer's maintain the upper hand.
They simply,
similarly some of the early
shot a mute ners mutiny mutiny.
Mutineers what? Yeah, mute nurse you say
mutinous I don't know people who mutiny.
I can't confuse these
things. So, um, they,
but they were massive. Uh, they,
but they had nothing to do with
socialist or an anarchist or passivist
propaganda at all. Uh, there were
attempts, there were congresses.
There was a congress in Sweden,
there was another one in Switzerland.
The French government would
not let representatives go
to those congresses. Um,
and the first reaction was,
you know,
in the high command was that while
the Socialists and the, you know,
now they're showing their true,
uh, uh, their, their true stripes,
anarchist propaganda is working the bowl.
Look at the Bolshevik revolution had
not yet happened. That was an October.
But the, uh, the Russian revolution
in February had already occurred.
It's nothing to do with it.
Uh, what they objected to,
they were not defeatist at all. They did
not want the Germans to win the war. Uh,
but they realize that they weren't going
to win the war either and that this
strategy was completely,
completely few tile. Uh,
there were cases of fraternization
there, very famous cases, um,
Christmas 1914,
and I'm the front way up near Belgium,
uh,
on the British side particularly. Uh,
they start yelling back and forth,
the Germans and the British and they
say, basically, screw this stuff.
Why don't we take the day off?
And so the Welsh were singing Christmas
carols to the Germans and the Germans
are getting their best singers and
sweating and, and, and uh, singing back.
They actually did get together
and play a soccer game.
They found a place that wasn't
totally chopped up and plate. In 1915,
uh, on Christmas, uh, British,
uh, uh, soldier said, why
don't we do the same thing?
And they put him up against
the wall and shot him.
There were these rumors that
very persistent during the whole,
the whole fighting and the western
front, that underneath, underneath glass,
we're, after all, all these
champagne caves are underneath.
And that was the town where the statue
of the Virgin Mary on the top of a church
hung like this and that the Germans,
that if it falls one way,
we're going to win for
falls the other way.
The French are going
to win that somewhere.
The people who are lucky enough
to be alive, we're down there.
And they would come out and take
it, take food, and they would take,
they would take a wine reiterations and,
and stuff like that.
They would take them back
from the, uh, from the dad.
And they were all partying under,
under underground,
and that they were the lucky ones
and they were all fraternizing.
It wasn't that case,
but still,
you hear all these stories and the
great war poets of saying, well, yeah,
so and so these two German, the guy in a,
in a British guy find themselves in, in,
in a, in a crater, uh,
both on the verge of death and they're
discussing Nicha until somebody finally
comes in and rescues them. I mean,
a lot of this may be apocryphal,
but the mutinies hadn't had to do,
not with defeatism.
It had to do with the sheer
madness of it all. And,
and, and it was mad. And, and there's
still historians who were saying, well,
you know, the creeping barrage
is if they hadn't made them,
they'd made them a little more organized
and maybe the breakthroughs would have
come and they're still defending the
impossible after all of these years.
Um,
and so
god,
okay,
something happened.
I want to show you these
please.
My turning up.
I think I'm turning it off.
Simon, can you, uh, God,
I am nude.
Uh,
it was very dark at the battle
of air done. What happens?
Can you do this?
Yeah,
yeah. Okay. I just, these are real ones
from fair dot. Unveiled then was 1916.
It begins in February. It rains all
the time. And that part of France,
and this will get at this to explain,
uh,
the mutinies is also to understand they're
done. This is reconnaissance plane, uh,
that,
those are craters
there.
Those are the creditors. Those are
some more craters over there. Next.
And then that Foret Du,
Du, Du I'm or, or volt.
And when you go to them and
you really should go to them.
I mean it's a long way from there,
down there, down at the top,
Donald is the town that's near there,
but the one, I'll never forget this.
When you go in and you see after the war,
like as people do in churches,
people would come and put plaques and
the most moving one is to my sons.
Since his eyes closed,
might've not deceased to cry.
Next one please. And so
that's, you'd be going in there
and that, those were where the plaques
are right there. This guy right there, uh,
there are plaques. Fact, that plaque
that I, that I just said is right on,
is right next to that there.
Now
you're here and they say over the top men.
Okay,
and you're trying to get
on the other side there.
How are you going to do that?
Okay.
Hi. That's all barbed wire around there.
How are you going to do that? You can,
these are just,
that's inside Volvo or do 'em all
night patrol. Again, there's a trash
and they're, they're, they're attacking.
But you've got to climb
over your own Barb wire too,
because that's Barb wire this
protecting you from if they attack.
And the casualty rates are just absolutely
phenomenal. You know, it, all these,
the Kashi rates here
are not the same as the,
as the song because it
wasn't a massive attack.
It's like you're defending it against
the Germans and there's taking care of
some people that are getting hurt.
I mean, it would have been hurt, uh,
carrying somebody back. I mean, the poor
guy, it looks a little peek in there.
Telephones.
The Russian phone system was so bad.
The Germans could hear every single word
that they said on the eastern front.
Next,
please.
Well,
you get the point.
There's the machine
guns aimed low medical.
Yeah.
Oh, that's fantastic to walk in there.
But you have to remember that, you know,
the lot of the fighting is on the outside
and the myth and the snow and the crap.
It's just a, it's an amazing
thing. But they help.
They held and marshal Petain I became
the hero, you know, a hero of France.
He would have a later incarnation in
World War II and we'll get back to them.
Uh, but they, they,
how are you going to run up
that hill, Karen? 60 pounds.
There was a comment by
the way called Dewa Mall,
which is the only commune
out of the 36,000 that no
longer exists because it was
so battered that there's a difference
in height in, in these hills of, of,
you know,
just of 15 a hundred feet and it
could never be rebuilt next please.
Yeah,
we get to get the scene
and it is amazing how little people
knew what they knew in the home front.
And there's a very good book edited by
Jay Winter and, and uh, his friend, uh,
there's only to be your whole bay,
I don't know about capital
cities at war about London,
Paris and Berlin comparing the home front.
And it's really good stuff is how
little people knew about this.
It's like an Italian said,
do people really imagine that we go,
that we just jump up and
down and screaming, long
live Italy? Uh, uh, it's, uh,
one of the most amazing things
is that people, uh, in the
hell actually more than,
uh,
more than didn't mute need that.
That's one of the most incredible
things about the, about the whole,
the whole bloody mass.
Now they died in the hell they
called it posh and Dale. Um,
that was a place where the
British gained four miles.
That's about a seven kilometers.
Um,
in exchange for 300,000 dead
or wounded 300,000, take uh,
uh,
take a football stadium like University
of Michigan or ut Austin and fill it up
three times and imagine that, you
know, those people. Uh, that's,
that's what it was like 19, 17, 19,
17 changes. It changes everything. Uh, 19,
17 changes everything because two key
events happen and there are obvious.
One is the Russian revolution
in 1917 in February.
That's a,
and then B,
this is still point number one is the
Russian revolution in, uh, in October.
And it's clear that the,
that the, uh, the Pr, the Pr,
we'll talk about this or
you can read about this.
The cremsky provisional government is
under tremendous pressure from the allies
to stay in the war,
but it's clear that when the Bolsheviks
seized power and October, 1917,
that the Russians are going to get
out of the war. And that that piece,
land and bread is a powerful,
powerful slogan for the Russian soldiers.
And it's amazing that the
Russian soldiers didn't all, uh,
go back to Vladivostok or to
Kazakhstan or to wherever, uh,
that they were able to hold
on as long as they did.
And so that's going to change
things. Is it that time that, um,
the second event happens and then
as the Americans come into the war,
now the Americans I,
outside of places like
Chicago and Milwaukee and
Philadelphia, maybe they had a,
lots of Germans, uh, most
people in the United States, uh,
the tendency was to want the allies
to lit, to, to, to, to win, uh,
the loser to fight another
day. And, and, uh, uh,
the Americans were angered by the
submarine warfare campaign in 1915 a boat
called the Lusitania was sunk.
Uh,
there had been a warnings posted
by the German government saying,
if you're a passenger, don't go on that
you're going to go into a war zone. Uh,
the Germans claimed when the, what was
sunk that was full of munitions, uh,
the Americans and the British said, no, it
was, and in fact, it was, and they were,
that was proved about 20 years
ago by divers and near Ireland.
And lots of people die.
And the Germans know that the only
way they can win the war is the, the,
the unrestricted campaign of, uh, of, uh,
a submarine warfare to try to keep
Britain from being supplied by American
supplies. And Wilson, who won
election, Woodrow Wilson, Princeton,
uh, who won election on the,
uh, he kept us out of war.
He takes the country into war,
uh,
and eventually he can't get the
treaty of Versailles past, even by,
by the American, uh,
isolationists, uh, senate. Um,
and so the Americans go to war
in 1917 I took a Yale Alumni,
besides taking the April
Neda drink champagne.
A lot of them wanted to go to this as
a long time, go to Chateau [inaudible],
which is the first place that American
soldiers fought in 19, in 1917. Um,
uh, but now it wasn't the American troops
that made the difference. I mean, the,
the, the, in the imaginary,
the imaginary, in the, in the,
in the perceptions of the French,
who was the rival of, uh, you know,
of general Pershing,
you know,
who had made his career sort
of a slaughtering Mexicans,
uh, uh, in, in Mexico.
Uh, he, um, uh, you know,
the image was at the far west was coming
in and these sort of gun toting a dodge
city types where we're going to turn
the tide. That's not what happens,
but what turns the tide is the,
once the Americans are in the war,
that the tremendous industrial
strength of the U S uh, it may,
it means the curves are gonna are
gonna Cross. And by that simply,
I mean the curves that, that
the, the Germans, no, they
ain't going to win the war.
Uh, and the, the, the, the British
and the French, uh, and the,
the American, uh, high command,
they know they're going to win the war
and they think they're going to win the
war in 1920 or 1921, maybe
19, 19. If all goes well.
There was a quote in there after they
just had at the cost of thousands of lives
I think is still in there. Uh, they
had got a, a couple of kilometers,
kilometers of carrot Tori back from the
Germans and somebody says, you know,
at this rate we'll get to the Rhine in
the year 2006, I think is what they,
what they figured. Um, and uh,
the long do a w I mean of being in for
four till the end was going to be a long
time if you were, if you were able to
survive. So those are the two big events.
The curves cross 1917 is also important
here because tanks begin to make a
difference. Tanks can't do
anything in the, in these
craters. They get stuck there.
What are those things? There? Treads,
you know, just sort of a spin,
like a car stuck in the snow in
north haven or something. Uh,
they don't make any difference
until, uh, until they actually,
they can break into the open and at
that point then they can be a way of
protecting infantry of behind them
of us in 1917 really turns it around.
And then making a long story
short yet again in 1918, I mean,
Luton Dwarf by this time,
Hindenburg and Ludendorff basically
have to have taken over the government
basically. Uh, the, um,
the Second Reich is now controlled
by, by the military. Of course,
Hindenburg has a rather pernicious role
in the long run to play because he was
determined to destroy the Weimar Republic,
even though it was as president.
And as he in 1932 says,
we'll bring in an odd off.
I will bring him in as
chancellor. Um, but anyway, uh,
so alluded to, I've said, look,
you know, we've got to do it
now. If we don't do it now,
it ain't never gonna happen.
And so they throw every conceivable
resource into this, uh, offensive.
Uh,
and they do break through.
They do break through and you
can look at the maps in the book.
They get along way,
but then it snaps back like a rubber band.
They overrun their supplies as
they had in 1914 in the big,
you know, big war offensive. In 1914,
they began to overrun their supplies.
They get tired, and then they're pushed
back. And at that point, you know,
at that point, the worst days of the
bombardment of Paris as a is ended, uh,
uh, the, the, the allies are sure they're
there, they're going to win the war. And,
and that, uh, the Germans and
the Austrians hearing empire,
which is almost on the verge of collapse,
a,
despite the sheer inefficiency
of the Italian, uh, uh, military,
uh, um, they, they know
that it's going to collapse.
And that Russia's coming out of the war
in the long run did not make that much
of a difference.
Um,
because Italians are able to stabilize
really the front end in Austria, Hungary,
and the whole thing is, is
going to collapse. And the
Austrian Hungarian Empire,
the nationalities are putting forward
their claims and Franz Joseph Dies in
1916. Um, and it's not going
to go that long. And finally,
on the 11th of November in 1918
in a railroad car in [inaudible],
near [inaudible] in the forest,
uh, not very far north of Paris,
uh, they, uh,
sign on the dotted line and the
armistice is declared a in 1940,
Hitler would, would accept
a Francis Surrender, uh, in,
it wasn't actually the same railroad car,
but he,
they told him it was also
in the forest and comb PN,
a near called PN in, um, uh, in 1940.
Uh, and the war, the war ended.
Now the more about this later, um, but,
um,
the
basically that France in
victory is not as strong as,
as Germany and defeat because
Germany is an industrially, uh,
much more, uh, prosperous
country. And this will,
this will hang over the negotiations
at Versailles because the French demand
that somebody pay for the war of which
France suffered more than any other
country, uh, in terms of its agricultural
land being chewed up, the finest land, uh,
uh, in France, et Cetera, et
cetera. So that's going to
hang over the priest piece,
uh,
proceedings.
But I want to make it just a few comments
before I end with was j winter and we
have five minutes left. So I'm going to
do that. Uh, the highest percentage of,
of of a losses was France with
16.8% of those mobilized killed,
uh, in Germany, 15.4% killed.
But if you take those in, in actually
in combat is 22% officers in 18%.
A soldier's cause.
Remember officers,
they weren't all fancy generals who
were sitting drinking champagne,
plotting the deaths of all these people,
the junior officers,
and particularly not particularly,
but also the case in the British sense,
the flower, British youth from
Oxford, Cambridge, etc. Etc.
They're the ones that blew the
whistle, said, follow me man.
And they jump over armed with only a
pistol there, toast, you know, they,
they get killed. Uh, even in
greater percentages anyway,
Serbia loses 37% of all it's common
sense that come combat. And that's not,
they don't have as many
Turkey, 27%, Romania,
25% and Bulgaria 22%.
Now sink of this,
the worst starts in early August,
1914 and ends on the 11th of November,
1918 every day of those years,
every day,
think four years back in your own lives.
And then everyday be the 900
freshmen were killed every day,
every day. That's a lot of
telegrams. Be Proud of X.
1300 Germans were killed every day.
The death rate was higher. And World
War II, of course, in World War II,
the Soviet Union, it has an unbelievable
death rate. 25 million people die,
some of them in Stalin's Gulag, but
most of them because of the war, uh,
the death rate is higher.
Uh, July 1st, 1916,
just the first day of
the battle of the Somme,
20,000 British soldiers were killed,
not just killed and wounded.
Then in one day,
so they were there to go over the
top and they're dead at the end. Um,
unlike previous wars, disease didn't
play a major part. Unlike for example,
the Crimean war though the blue flu
sometimes called the Spanish flu,
uh, as you know, will kill
more people in 1918, 19, 19,
1920 then the war, that's, I mean,
that's the big pan. And Demi,
um, as I said, most people
die of old, of, of a,
of shells followed by machine guns and
flames despite a progress in medicine.
Now also things like shellshock were first
identified at this time after the war.
Freud was very interested in that among
other people. So the psychological,
I wasn't just that you went into the
Paris metro or the London tube and you saw
people begging with one
arm or one leg or no legs,
is that you saw people who had also choked
out their lungs on gas. We were blind.
They were all over the place.
And Europe was a country of widows,
especially in countries like Italy where
when widow's still wore black all the
time, Europe was a country of widows.
If you had a demographic curve,
a triangle,
it was like a shark had it had eaten
a huge bite out of the male population
between 18 and say 55 um,
no one had ever seen.
The lengths was simply staggering.
The Battle of the Somme
lasted five months.
Gallipoli's lasted more than eight months,
veer done 10 months.
He put in 1917,
four months on the battle of the Somme.
You talk about how war
influenced people's lives.
4 million men participated in the
battle of the Somme. 4 million.
That's a phenomenal statistic. More
than a quarter were killed, captured,
or [inaudible] or
classified as disappeared,
disappeared.
Nothing left battlefields.
We're no longer called the field of
glory that went. The language went.
I make an illusion to that, which is an
obvious one at the end of what you read.
Also,
there's a brutalization of the sense of
humanity that you lost because you were
dealing with so many people dead all
around. You are fighting for your life,
that the attitude that people
had toward other people changes,
and the Demons of the 20th century
fascism above all would be built on that
dehumanization. Difficult to
imagine though, not impossible,
the whole accost without world war one.
But given the Turks and the,
and what they did to the Armenians,
it's hard to say also atrocities.
There were atrocities. Now, there are a
couple of good books on atrocities. Uh,
most of the atrocities were committed
by the Germans in Belgium. Uh,
they gunned down.
They executed 5,500 Belgian civilians.
And EAD Cavallo was the
most famous, the nurse, um,
to p in part because German
soldiers believed that they
were being picked off by
civilians,
is a,
what had happened in France in 1870 to 71.
But the Russians, uh, uh, committed the
atrocities in east Prussia and in Galicia,
the Austrians who had been told that
the Serbs were subhuman committed
atrocities there, there were rapes not
yet raped, had not become an arm of, of,
of combat as it would with
Russians after World War Two. Uh,
but people were treated
like a, uh, like animals.
Hitler said in 1939,
after all,
who will remember the Armenians,
that that's an incredible chilling thing.
So I want to end simply,
uh, with uh, with Jay,
with Jay winter, whom you're going to meet
soon. So maybe I can find this. And um,
it's about a haunting
film done by about Goss.
It's called j'accuse. I accused, it's
not the same thing as well as Iq is,
but it's another one made in 1918 to 1919.
The hero,
John Diaz is a wounded soldier,
poet. He begins to lose his mind.
He escaped from the hospital and
he reaches his village there.
He summons the villagers and
he tells them of a dream.
It starts in a battlefield graveyard with
wooden crosses all here and there and
everywhere.
A huge black cloud rises above it and
magically ghostlike figures emerged from
the ground. They're wrapped and
tattered bandages. Some limping,
some blind walking with ups raised arms,
stomach blindly like
Frankenstein's monster.
They leave the battlefield
and they go home.
They go from the graves to their
villages and they want to see if their
sacrifices have been in vain and
they get back to their villages.
And what they find is that their
wives have cheated on them.
They find that the people are
still ripping people off by faults,
waits at the market.
Uh,
the petty ways have continued
despite the horrific losses.
And they say,
you must manage your ways.
We didn't go through all of this hell so
that you would continue to behave like
you do the world after all must be a
better place. Isn't it a better place now?
Won't it be? That's the big
illusion, by the way, about 1920s,
1930s because the world wasn't going
to be a better place. It wasn't at all.
And they believe their mission is
fulfilled and they go back to their graves
after we're counting this dream.
The poet now totally mad.
Accuses The sun above of standing idly
by and watching the war go on and then he
dies. Now, the one of the
oddest thing about this,
about how art and railed emerge is that
this film was made before the end of the
war. And I bet a goss, the producer,
got permission from the army to have
real soldiers be extras in his movie.
And you can see real people who are not
going back to the front with their arms
ripped off stumps.
They had stumps and some of the people
who were in that movie went back to the
front and were killed and
they didn't survive the war.
The war had taken a terrible
vengeance. Now, both in art,
joys of, of, of great artistic
production, but on reality to it.
It's an incredible scene. And of
course, things couldn't be back again.
You couldn't go back to your village,
you couldn't give back.
Get off a bus at the end of the,
uh,
and go back and fall into
the arms of your family and,
and stand there with tears in your cheeks
as you're counting off the names of
the dead people that you knew things
were going to get better, but they don't.
And one way of looking at the entire
period in 1914 to 1945 and Jay,
we'll talk about this,
is to view it as an entire more horrible
30 years' war cause things don't get
better. They get worse. If that's
even possible. On that light note,
I wish you a happy election.